hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and it finally
happened after merlin yet another
original sin has returned in the seven
deadly sins sequel and this sin is
actually playing a major role in the
current arc of the story things are
heating up quickly in the four nights of
the apocalypse manga netflix just
announced a new animated movie that
focuses on tristan the son of meliotis
and elizabeth and there is so much to
talk about so let's get into it if you
guys enjoy our seven daily sins and four
nights of the apocalypse content and you
want to see more in the future please
leave a like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps a lot and if you're
new to anime pro or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror it
should go without saying that this video
will contain spoilers for the seven
deadly sin sequels so please proceed
with caution you have been warned okay
first up let's talk about the new seven
deadly sins movie that was just
announced a two-part seven deadly sins
spin-off movie called garage of
edinburgh is coming in 2022 and it will
focus on tristan now i'm definitely
interested in the plot but i am
definitely not excited about the cgi
animation to be honest the teaser
trailer we got basically looks like a
cut scene from the seven deadly sins
grand cross game so yeah
after amazing animation in the first two
seasons of the anime it seems that seven
deadly sins fans are cursed to deal with
subpar animation and speaking of cursed
in case you missed it i made an entire
video on the cursed by light 7 deadly
sins movie it has an interesting plot
that adds to the original story and
develops the backstory for the sequel so
be sure to check out that video if you
haven't already i will link it in the
description and in the pinned comment
okay so now on to the latest twists and
turns in the sequel manga after the big
showdown with ironside in sistana the
journey to leonis continues and the main
crew is now made up of percival donnie
naciens and anne's horse sylvan and
cynda fox during a brief stopover at the
town of kant we saw the return of hauser
who is now a captain of the holy knights
of leonis and who turns out to be doni's
uncle donny's mother is hauser's sister
who sadly passed away when donny was
just a kid we also saw our heroes fight
off an actual dragon which was extremely
cool at the end of the arc hauser warns
the gang that as long as they are
carrying dragon handle with them they
will be a target for the forces of
camelot as a fragment of the coffin of
eternal darkness dragon handle carries a
lot of power and that makes its wielder
a constant target not surprisingly
percival volunteers to carry it anyway
so hauser who is a skilled blacksmith
attaches a new blade to dragon handle
this turns dragon handle into a
functional sword for percival and beyond
this a lot more happened during this arc
but i just won't spend too much time
covering it i want to just get right
into the current arc which features a
secret village full of demons and the
return of another member of the original
seven deadly sins as our heroes continue
their journey they have to cross the
peaks of fear a large mountain range
that constitutes the single biggest
geographical obstacle on the way to
leonis these mountains are apparently
known as a hotbed of eerie mystical
powers and they often induce strange
illusions and visions in travelers
cinderfox sees one of these visions as
the gang sets up camp for the night he
sees a strange woman who is dressed like
a bride and who calls him by his name
something that shocks sin we don't see
what name she uses but we can assume
that his real name is something other
than sin if the woman had just called
him sin there would be no reason for him
to be so shocked because everyone else
knows him as sin now no one else in the
party saw this strange woman only sin
and this seems to support the theory
that sin is not really who he claims to
be i keep thinking and hoping that he is
actually born the fox's sin of greed and
that he was somehow turned into a fox
against his will in order to hide his
identity while he figures out how to
return to his human form bond just
adopted the name sin as in fox's sin
that would definitely make sense to me
especially if this strange woman was
somehow connected to the lady of the
lake the person who abducted bond's son
lancelot we'll have to wait and see i am
100 sure that sin is directly connected
to bonn and lancelot in some way i'm
just not sure how exactly my guess is
that sin is actually bon but that's just
a hunch the gang suddenly comes across a
hidden village near the summit of the
mountain range the villagers notice them
and start smiling and waving and while
percival and donny are intrigued and
asians think this village is kind of
weird then a man shows up with his dog
and he warns the gang not to go into the
village because it is dangerous but it's
already too late for percival and donny
who are heading for the village as we
speak at full speed sin rushes in after
them in an attempt to turn them away and
they end up passing through some sort of
magical barrier which apparently traps
them inside the village as we see all
the villagers smiling with eyes that
look completely blank the man with the
dog tells anne and aseans that the
village their friends just ran into is
no village at all it is a den of
monsters it's pretty obvious from the
start that something is off with this
village but that is only the beginning
of the drama that ensues during this arc
the crazy twists just keep coming and i
actually love them so let me walk you
through all of them the man with the dog
introduces himself as a hunter named ard
and he explains that this mysterious
village appeared only 10 years ago and
while the people inside the village may
appear like normal people as soon as any
of them leaves the magical barrier that
surrounds the village they instantly
turn into monsters the leader of the
village is especially interesting he's a
tall elderly bearded man and sin is
immediately suspicious of him according
to sin this village elder has been using
some sort of bird to spy on our heroes
since before they entered the mountains
and then when percival reveals that the
fox's name is sin the elder has the
exact same reaction as me he's like sin
the fox's name is sin sin the fox and
i'm just like yes bro this guy gets it
it has to be directly related to bon the
fox's sin of greed anyway the elder asks
in to talk to him in private and the two
of them leave while percival and donnie
are served a bunch of food by the other
villagers meanwhile in their private
meeting the elder seems to have knocked
sin out i mean sin is literally on the
floor passed out and the elder tells
them to rest as long as he'd like as all
of this is happening in the village art
explains to ana asians that the only way
to help their friends escape is to
destroy the strange stone idol at the
center of the village art volunteers to
create a diversion while ananasians
destroy the idol and although nazianz is
suspicious about why art would be so
eager to risk his own life to help them
ann assures him that art hasn't lied
about anything since she has the power
to detect lies we have to assume that
art is being sincere when he says that
he just wants to prevent innocent people
from being hurt by these monsters so art
proceeds with his distraction while ana
and asians head for the idol at first
they think that donny and percival are
being attacked by the villagers but it
turns out that they're just having a
great time playing around strangely
enough percival is able to communicate
with the villagers even though they
speak a foreign language that does not
originate in britannia and percival
doesn't even seem to know why he can
understand the language which isn't even
surprising when it comes to percival
it's just how he rolls and then manages
to destroy the idol with the help of her
horse and then suddenly all of the
villagers are revealed for what they
truly are they are not humans all of
them are demons more specifically they
are all lower ranked red and grey demons
that we are so familiar with from the
original series as the villager's true
form is revealed art reveals his own
true identity he is actually a holy
night of camelot and he is committed to
returning britannia to the human race
even if that means exterminating
everyone else oh and also his dog is
actually a monster so there's that but
here's the interesting thing anne is
expecting that these horrible demons are
gonna attack them and eat her friends
but the demons turn out to be extremely
nice they weren't putting up an act
earlier when they were in human form
they really are just chill guys and they
really do want to be friends with
percival and the others despite their
demonic appearance and despite what we
saw other red and grey demons do in the
past these particular demons really are
peace loving creatures but now that the
idol has been broken the holy knight
ardberg formerly known as ard has
infiltrated the village he is a holy
knight in king arthur's service and he
vows to exterminate all of these members
of the demon clan the elder tries to
explain that these demons refused to
fight in the holy war and that they
decided to hide out here specifically
because they didn't want to hurt anyone
but ardberg doesn't care he believes
that all demons are evil without
exception and that they all must be
destroyed in order to protect humans
ardberg then uses a crystal known as the
amber of the four archangels to seal the
demons away artberg also realizes that
percival is one of the rumored four
knights of the apocalypse and after
percival demands the release of his
demon friends artberg attacks percival
the holy knight believes that
associating with the demon clan in any
way is evil and the fact that percival
is willing to call demons his friends
means that the prophecy must be true
percival really will destroy the world
unless he is stopped so artberg pledges
to kill percival although he doesn't
want to hurt anne and as he ends and he
tells them to just leave so he's not
just some sadistic psycho who wants to
kill everyone he only wants to eliminate
those creatures he believes are a threat
to humans ardberg's dog also goes after
percival although he is no longer a dog
he is now a giant monster with antlers
or horns he turns out to be a cernonos a
legendary godly beast with massive horns
who is said to reside in the depths of
hell i wonder if depths of hell here is
referring to purgatory because this
beast definitely looks like it could be
a creature of purgatory either way
though we have already seen a giant horn
of a cernuno's beast in the original
manga as you'll recall this horn served
as a vessel for one of the goddesses an
intense battle between cernunnos and
percival ensues percival is almost eaten
by the beast but thankfully he is able
to use his overpowered hope magic to
push the beast back and then
counter-attack however whenever percival
tries to slice the beast's horns with
his sword nothing happens apparently
sereno's horns are extremely hard and
not even steel can cut them meanwhile
sin finally wakes up just in time to
witness this crazy battle go down for
her part ann threatens ardberg with a
sword and tries to get him to call off
his beast she is also surprised that she
wasn't able to detect ardberg's lies
even though he clearly tricked them but
artberg explains that everything he said
was true he really is a hunter but he
hunts demons not animals he also really
did want to save innocent people but in
his mind the only way to save them is to
exterminate all demons so ardberg really
was sincere the whole time just not in
the way that anne had anticipated this
kind of shows the limitations of anne's
lie detecting powers in a very
interesting way ardberg explains to our
heroes that they are just too young to
understand the truth about the demons
they don't know what happened during the
holy war and how many innocent people
were mercilessly slaughtered by the
demon clan entire families were wiped
out parents lost their own innocent
children because of demons and so the
only way to protect humanity from
further suffering in the future is to
eliminate the entire demon clan percival
is still struggling with the beast
because he just can't cut through the
horns but sin has a suggestion he tells
percival to infuse his dragon handle
sword with his hope magic which ends up
increasing the power of his sword
exponentially with his newly boosted
weapon percival is able to cut off the
horns with ease after being nearly eaten
at one point percival manages to defeat
the beast with an assist from nazians
our heroes then prepare to take on
ardberg himself but when they turn
around they realize that he's already
running away at full speed he tries to
play it cool and call it a strategic
retreat which reminds me of my boy
joseph joestar so i have to give artberg
respect for that now technically the
gang could just leave artberg and
continue their journey to leonis but
purse will insist that they must rescue
his demon friends from ardberg's crystal
seal the fact that percival wants to
rescue the villagers even after learning
that they are actually demons surprises
the elder but percival insists that the
fact that some demons did bad things in
the past doesn't mean that all of them
are bad just like the fact that his
father killed his grandfather doesn't
mean that all humans are bad if you're a
good guy it doesn't matter whether
you're a human or a demon this seems to
really warm the elder's heart and he
decides to place his faith in percival
and the others the gang follows artberg
to a cavernous crystal grotto that turns
out to be a giant maze and of course it
is also a trap artberg's magic is not
good for direct battles so he is not a
fighter but if he can trap his opponents
in a specific way he can use his magic
to defeat them his magic is the ability
to revert all living things within a
50-yard radius into their infant forms
and that is exactly what happens to
percival naciennes ann and donny they
are turned into adorable little toddlers
who can barely walk on their own
needless to say they are now in no
condition to fight they're just babies
after all and that means that aardberg
has won well percival is still
freakishly strong even as a baby so he
turns out to be a bit bothersome but at
the end of the day he has still mentally
reverted to a baby so he isn't really
hard to beat however things change when
anne begins to cry she weeps and begs
artberg not to hurt her friends in this
moment little crying anne reminds
artberg of his own young daughter his
daughter who it turns out was brutally
murdered by demons during the holy war
that is why artberg is so committed to
destroying the demon clan they killed
his innocent young daughter for no
reason and so he concluded that all
demons must be evil monsters he decided
to avenge his daughter while also making
sure that no other humans suffer his
tragic fate in the future so he
dedicated his life to exterminating all
demons and that is about the time that
the elder suddenly appears inside the
grotto he tells artberg that he now
understands why the holy knight is doing
what he's doing the elder also knows
that artberg desperately longs to meet
his daughter again artberg denies this
at first but then the elder offers him a
deal if artberg reverses the spell that
he placed on percival and the others and
if he gives back the crystal with the
demons the elder will let him meet his
daughter again artberg doesn't believe
that this is even possible at first but
he can tell that something is off with
the elder he was not sealed away in the
crystal so he is not a demon but the
baby spell also doesn't work on him for
some reason so he's probably not human
either the elder says that according to
the rules of artberg's magic it takes
one minute for someone to get younger by
one year so for percival and the others
it only took 16 minutes to turn them
into babies but the elder explains that
due to the fact that he is over three
thousand years old it would take three
whole days for ardberg's spell to work
on him the elder then strikes a
flamboyant pose that reveals his true
identity that's right the elder is not a
demon or a human he is none other than
the goat sin of lust gother now it makes
sense why the elder made that connection
between sin the fox and the fox's sin of
greed although the part about gother
putting sin to sleep doesn't make much
sense and neither does gother's choice
of wardrobe but moving on goether
introduces himself as one of the seven
deadly sins the so-called sworn enemies
of king arthur what a freaking twist
even though i suspected that something
was off about the elder i definitely did
not expect him to turn out to be one of
the original seven deadly sins and yes
it's our boy gother i guess gother
became the elder because he decided to
help those peace-loving demons who are
essentially refugees from the demon
realm but who are also feared and hated
by everyone in the human realm artberg
knows that he doesn't stand a chance of
defeating one of the seven deadly sins
so he decides to just run for it he
still believes that killing percival is
the right thing to do because if one of
the four knights of the apocalypse is
allowed to live he will eventually
destroy the world once gother catches up
to artberg the holy knight orders him to
stay away or he will throw baby percival
and baby anne into a canyon and kill
them but then golther shows artberg that
he is holding ardberg's own daughter an
adorable little baby girl and he then
asks artberg if he would really kill
percival and anne in front of his own
daughter now the little girl is just a
vision that gotha created from artberg's
memories and artberg knows that it's
just a mirage but it is so realistic
that he can't help but cry tears of joy
he agrees to lift the spell on percival
and the others and he recalls what
happened after he lost his daughter all
those years ago his powers only awoke
after he lost his daughter they seemed
to have been triggered by the tragic
event and after that king arthur came to
him and asked him whether he wants to
see his daughter again alive and well if
so then he must join arthur and lend him
his powers even though artberg thought
this was a ridiculous proposition the
look in arthur's eyes convinced him that
the king was serious so wait does this
mean that arthur knows of a real way to
revive the dead if so then this is a
massive reveal that is going to be
extremely important later on so artberg
agreed to serve king arthur and he
embraced arthur's mission to banish all
the demons and make the world safe for
humanity hardbrook says that he sees the
light now no one can really bring back
the dead and his daughter is gone but he
appreciates go through allowing him to
see his daughter one last time just the
way he had remembered her then out of
nowhere gother senses that two spears
infused with magic are flying right at
them and they seem to be targeting
percival golther is able to save
percival using an epic acrobatic
maneuver but after golther takes
percival out of harm's way the second
spear is heading straight for baby anne
artberg tells his daughter or the vision
of his daughter to hold on a sec because
daddy will be coming to see her soon he
then rescues anne by lifting her over
his shoulders and out of harm's way but
at the cost of the spear piercing right
through his own torso artberg sacrifices
his life to save anne and his last words
to her are to grow up and be a great
woman wow the twists in this arc are
just insane the villagers are demons the
honest and sincere hunter guy is a
holding out of camelot who wants to kill
percival the village elder is actually
gother and then in the end artberg
sacrifices his life to save anne in what
ends up being a wholesome and
heartbreaking moment i have to say that
i was really impressed by this arc and
there is a lot of depth here in the
early stages of the original seven
deadly sin story our impressions of the
demons and especially those low level
demons is almost exclusively negative
and yet in life things are never so
simple and there are indeed good and bad
demons just like there are good and bad
humans i'm so glad that the sequel story
decided to explore this topic and
artberg ended up being such a freaking
interesting character on the one hand
his decision to target all demons and
even percival just because of his
preconceived assumptions is clearly bad
and yet you can see where he's coming
from after you learn his tragic
backstory after all some demons really
are monsters just like some humans are
monsters as well and artberg had the bad
luck to meet some of those evil demons
first hand those evil demons then
informed his opinion of all demons and
yet now we meet demons who literally
risked their lives to avoid killing
humans they had to flee the demon realm
because refusing to fight in the holy
war was the same as treason from the
perspective of the demon clan and on top
of all of that we have gother just
hanging out with the demons and
protecting them this makes sense since
golthar's creator the original golter
was also a demon who wanted peace and
opposed the holy war so by protecting
these demons gother is honoring the
memory of his creator but that epic
reveal aside what will gother do now
will he continue just chilling in the
demon village or will he now join our
heroes on their journey also did gother
figure out sin's true identity and is
sin actually bond if so will we see
bonds human form soon oh and who was
that bride from sin's strange vision is
she related to the fact that arthur is
currently looking for a bride finally
who sent those magic spears after
percival man so many interesting
questions this was easily the best arc
of the sequel manga so far and how funny
would it be if it turned out that sin
really was bon all along i know a lot of
fans were complaining that nakaba should
have featured the original sins more
prominently in the sequel manga so how
hilarious would it be if bon was
actually there the whole time definitely
let me know what you guys think about
the return of golfer this current arc of
the manga and sins true identity down in
the comments below i always love hearing
from you if you guys enjoyed this video
and you want to see more seven deadly
sins and four nights of the apocalypse
content here on the channel just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps with the
youtube algorithm and if you're new to
the channel or you watch our videos but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
hit the bell and then select the option
that says all if you don't do that
you're going to miss a ton of our videos
in the future it's just the way youtube
works you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twego himself i also
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata al-jatal
pate heffa hinokami and water the
toasted cheek corey mcgowan the spike
kaido might be a gyarados dylan isidore
spidey life tinel tungsten tarkis baked
buddhist monkey d quilly cody hebert and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the
red-haired ravens steelers on hell crews
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia fat boy games jessica
rabbit and jeremy phillips if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you